Game of Thrones star Kit Harington is
taking some time to work on personal
issues ET can confirm at the 32 year old
actor who played Jon Snow on the hit HBO
series checked himself into a wellness
retreat facility and according to
multiple reports he did so weeks before
the series finale aired on May 19th
sorry according to page 6 kit has been
at the luxury mental health retreat in
Connecticut for a month addressing
issues related to stress exhaustion and
alcohol use a rep for kit tells ET kit
has decided to utilize this break in his
schedule as an opportunity to spend some
time at a wellness retreat to work on
some personal issues I don't know how
I'm gonna feel when it's
was over either et last spoke with
Harrington in April at the Game of
Thrones season 8 premiere in New York
City where he talked about how the show
made a sweet impact on his life as
that's where he met his future wife the
two began dating while filming
congratulations the final season
premiere this show has been more than a
decade of your life how are you
preparing for it all to end it kind of
in some ways has ended for us you know
we finished when we finished filming we
we said goodbye to it so it's this is
sort of just seems like an added bonus
that we're getting to watch it and
celebrate it now I'm it's I'm kind of I
said to Rose the other night I was like
we've been tethered by this show for a
long time we've loved it and now we get
to enjoy the final hurrah
[Music]